hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game uh from the 35th edition of
the leon masters it is andreas penco
versus the legend boris girlfriend and
um you guys basically requested at least
one game from this match because this is
the semi-finals the winner of the
semifinals gets to play vishwanathan
anand for the finals of the 35th edition
of the leon masters
and this is the game that i have chosen
as it features uh a wonderful line
against the sicilian defense one of the
one line that i particularly enjoy
playing in faster time formats and it
includes the absolute strongest move
there ever was uh in in chess altogether
but we'll get to that
so basically the format that they use is
they play four rapid games with the four
rapid games send in a draw then we have
two blitz games three plus two uh the
time control and then if that ends in a
draw then we have the armageddon and
this is what happened uh uh in the
actual match so they played all of those
seven games and then of course a winner
emerged we're going to discuss this this
a little bit later but this is the game
i want to show you it's the second game
of the rapids and it is a truly an
enjoyable one so let's dive straight
into it is panko has the white pieces
and he opens with pawn to e4 we have c5
by girlfriend he goes for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 knights to c6 and
now bishop to b5 going for dinos medina
rossolimo attack uh pawn to e6 we have
castles and the knight g to e7 and this
is all very very standard stuff but this
is where espanku plays a move that has
never been played um in this position of
course uh in top tier competition and
that is pawn to b4 and that is the move
you usually see in some very tricky
openings like maybe the evans gambit or
maybe you know some some other sidelines
where you want to challenge the the c5
pawn uh but here uh it's uh incredibly
tricky to pull it off because uh well
it's just not as powerful as in the
evans gambit but still it's very very
tricky to play it uh now uh here a
girlfriend could capture the pawn with
the pawn if you go something like this
then we could go pawn to d4 then we grab
the full center or we challenge the
structure even further we play three
challenge the b for pawn if b captures
then we play d4 then we can capture with
the knight with the bishop and so on
however here girlfriend shows that he is
uh
well uh
that he knows his stuff and he plays
knight captors on b4 even though
this is the engine's second
recommendation it is uh somewhat easier
to play with black and also when you
play this with white you prefer when
people just capture with the pawn
because the the pawn leaves the center
and that's kind of what you want to do
so here c3 challenging the knight and
here uh girlfriend again doesn't go back
right away now if you go back then d4
and then you are playing right into
white's hands but here we have a6
challenging the bishop now asking okay
if you move the bishop then i'm going to
move the knight back but also i think
golfunder does this because it's a
useful move you want to play it at some
point regardless of when you move the
knight but also maybe to force this
pengu to burn a bit more time so here is
pango decides to capture the knight it
is by far the strongest move a captures
on b5 and now b captures on c5 and boris
plays b6 challenges the c5 pawn and now
uh offers uh the the the trade on b6 and
now if you look at this white tried to
sacrifice some material for rapid
development uh but boris said nope i
will not be accepting any material today
i also wish to develop my pieces rapidly
so here d4 grabbing the center b
captures on c5 and the d captures on c5
now with full control over the d6 square
uh so knight the c6 developing the
knight now also you regain some control
over the d6 square and now bishop to e3
we have bishop to e7 preparing to castle
and now comes pawn to e5 now espnko
fully controls the d6 square and if you
imagine let's say this knight being on
d6 that could be a problem or maybe this
knight knight c3 knight to e4 knight to
d6 so boris has to be very careful here
and you could consider castling here you
could you could consider definitely
playing b4 here preventing knights the
c3 you could consider a lot of things
but boris plays f5 he says this will be
very useful i want to castle king side
and you will
it will be much harder to attack the
king side with this pawn
advanced here and you don't really care
about uh weakening the position because
the pawn will remain on d6 on d7 it's
not very likely that this pawn will be
able to move so here knight to c3 we
have bishop to a6 now defending the b5
pawn and rook to e1 it makes sense to
move the rook from this diagonal we have
castles by girlfriend and now knight to
e2 uh we have queen to c7 continuing
development putting pressure on this e5
pawn and knight to f4 and now what is
happening here is this uh is this is
this a free pawn basically not really if
you go for knight captures on e5 uh then
we're going to capture and after queen
captures then a white queen captures on
d7 and this is not a problem the bishop
is hanging the pawn on e6 is hanging you
already created a pass pawn so you don't
want to do this so instead we have
knight to a5 uh and now uh we have a
ponta h4 is penco starts marching
forward with the pawn he wants to open
up the king's side knight to c4
attacking the bishop and the bishop to
d4 so everything is is solid for the
moment bishop back to b7 as the bishop
no longer is useful on this diagonal so
bishop to b7 will be much more useful
here knight the g5 now we have bishop to
g5 removing one of the attackers h
captures and now rook to a4
and now uh the rook can be shifted
throughout the entire fourth rank and
also it's quite a nice square for the
rook the other rook might also join him
rook after rook f38 might be played so
queen to b3 putting pressure on the b5
pawn and now bishop the c6 defending the
pawn uh and here
the girlfriend's position is just much
much better it's very hard for white to
get the rooks into the game the bishop
isn't all that useful you know just
guarding the the two pawns it's very
hard to make use of the knight uh and
here you could uh play something like g6
to try and make it a little bit trickier
but of course black will play h6 and
nothing is really happening here however
after his pink has moved rook to e2 uh
boris can now win the game by force and
it's quite a nice thing to spot so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the absolute strongest idea for
gale fund while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to a3 rook to a3 uh point being and
congratulations to everyone who found
this uh the point is you want to play
queen to d8 you want to go not after the
pawn you just want to grab hold of this
diagonal and then if the pawn moves you
can even move the queen to h4 the
problem is if you play this now white
will just play queen to g3 guard the
pawn and then the queen will also help
out with the defense of the king side by
playing rook to a3 you make this
impossible and you also add another
attacker into the game so here you could
go queen before queen to c2 queen to d1
uh queen to d1 was played in the game
and now girlfriend plays uh queen to d8
he goes after the pawn and there aren't
all that many ways you can defend this
pawn for example if you play something
like knights to h3 we are very happily
capturing this knight rook captures an
h3 also one of the reasons why the rook
is so powerful here and of course if the
rook is captured queen captures and g5
check and now you will just get
checkmated so instead we have g6 here
trying to stir some trouble but just
queen to h4 completely ignoring this
pawn we have queen to c1 you have to
defend the knight on f4 so queen to c1
also you put pressure on the rook so now
the knight can't move uh h captures on
g6 and now bishop to b2 again if you
play knight captures then the bishop
hangs so bishop back to b2 attacking the
rook and the now girlfriend plays pawn
to g5 now puts pressure on the knight he
offers the rook on a3 first knight to g6
attacking the queen here queen to h5 and
now knights the e7 cherokee yes saves
the knight and he will capture some
material later uh but after king to f7
uh there really isn't a good move here
for uh for esi panko now in the game
knight captures and c6 was played boris
played rook to h8 and he was in this
position on move 29 that andreas penco
resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you are getting checkmated and that's
pretty much it if f3 uh it's still uh
insufficient we just play rook captures
on f3 also one of the reasons why rook
to a rook to a3 was such a powerful idea
and now your position is completely
busted if g captures now you play queen
h1 check king f2 and you check made the
white king king eg3 queen
rook h3 checking f2 and now of course uh
we end with rook captures on f3
checkmate but even if
in this position uh yes pinko did not go
after the bishop if you play something
like f3 makes sense now you you can
start running away with the king right
away still rook h8 and after let's say
bishop captures an a3 now you eliminate
the rook so you don't allow any any uh
captures here still just queen to h1 uh
one checking f2 queen to h for which a
king you want and now bishop captures
and f3 you shattered
the the king's defenses either way g
captures uh queen h1 check and now it's
gonna be the exact same check made with
the rook h3 check king of two and rook
captures on f3 so really really
incredible stuff by boris i really
really liked the attempt uh
yes benko uh had uh here with this
beautiful b4 uh pawn move i pretty much
played this in all of my bullet games
and uh most of my blitz games weren't
playing against the knight to c6
sicilian
and you always get some very exciting
play if you if you can you know
sacrifice some pawns here create a
strong center much like you would for
example in the evans gambit but here
against a legend like boris girlfriend
it did not uh
you know go through uh and boris takes
the win with the black pieces now also
what is interesting about this match is
that um
the rapid uh section uh both of them won
one game and two games were drawn so
they went into the blitz section uh
there is pink one one game and
girlfriend won one game and then they
went into armageddon uh where boris had
the black pieces and it was a rook end
game equal material everything
completely equal uh but this pink lost
on time but okay even if he even if he
didn't uh since it was an armageddon
game uh if it's a draw then uh the
player with the black pieces win so
boris would win the game uh either way
but still interestingly uh all five
games that uh were won in this match
were one with the black pieces so really
really incredible stuff and you can see
how uh it's not like you know in the old
days you know if you had the black piece
you were like okay i have to defend
players are just so good and they work
so hard on their defensive repertoires
that they just you know prevail much
more it would seem uh with the black
pieces now but yeah really really
exciting stuff really enjoyed the b4
idea by espanko so i hope you guys
enjoyed that
i prefer showing games where ideas that
start would be for win but i thought
this was a very exciting game so i hope
you guys don't mind and now we will have
uh boris girlfriend versus vishwanathan
anand in the uh finals of the eleven
masters but there are some other very
very strong events starting today so
we'll see
if we will be able to to cover most of
them uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
mata georgia always koster harbor uh
calm and dean avalor magoolis and steven
abrams for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the uh well the coverage of
the lion masters the finals checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day